Courtney has just pointed out
that today is November 17^(th),
the significance of which had
evaded me,
but it's the accession day of
Elizabeth I,
>
which would have been greeted
in the sixteenth and seventeenth
centuries with bell ringing and
so forth.
It's no longer kept as a
national holiday but it used to
be.
Okay, but today we have other
business, the Restoration and
the run-up to the so-called
Glorious Revolution of 1688.
So to start,
the Restoration of May 1660
clearly represented a fresh
start for the monarchy in
England.
But it was a fresh start that
has to be understood against the
background of past events which
could not be forgotten even
though people tried hard not to
talk about them.
The constitutional crisis of
1640 had of course arisen from a
functional breakdown in the
relationship between the crown
and the political nation;
a breakdown traceable
ultimately to their loss of
confidence in the purposes of
royal government and the fear,
in particular,
that royal policy was favoring
"popery and arbitrary
power."
Initially, that crisis of 1640
to '41 had led to the successful
efforts of the Long Parliament
to reverse the trend in royal
policy and to put limits on the
King for the future.
A civil war of course had to be
fought to try to preserve those
gains,
and in the course of the war
further dimensions of the
situation emerged,
notably the demand for
"liberty of
conscience."
So, in all of that,
as I described last week,
the one political moment which
might have produced a broadly
acceptable settlement had been
in 1647 when Cromwell and Ireton
offered Charles the Heads of the
Proposals as the basis for a
settlement.
But as you know,
that moment was lost with
disastrous consequences for the
King.
Well, the Restoration has to be
seen in this context of
well-remembered events.
It was intended to restore the
situation to what it had been in
1641 after the reforming
statutes of the Long Parliament,
with the addition of the
granting of some liberty of
conscience to Protestant
dissenters,
which Charles II had promised
in his Declaration of Breda.
And if this had happened it
might indeed have provided a
lasting settlement--but
unfortunately it didn't work out
that way.
The architect of the
Restoration settlement was
Edward Hyde, the Earl of
Clarendon, Charles II's chief
minister at the beginning of his
reign;
a man who'd served his father
and advised the young King
throughout his period of exile.
Now Clarendon was very much a
constitutional royalist.
His essential idea was a return
to the constitutional situation
of 1641 including the reforms,
which he had supported at the
time before the outbreak of war,
with just some modifications
where necessary.
In the Convention Parliament
which began the Restoration in
1660,
all of the acts of parliament
which had been signed by Charles
I before the outbreak of war
were confirmed.
That included all the reforms
and it included the Triennial
Act laying down that a
parliament should meet at least
every three years.
In addition,
royal land which had been
confiscated during the Republic
was restored to it,
church land which had been
confiscated was restored to the
Church of England,
an indemnity was granted to the
army for all acts committed
during the war,
they were paid,
and they were disbanded except
for a number of guard's
regiments which were kept in
London about the King.
In addition,
Parliament passed a general Act
of Indemnity and Oblivion to
cover both sides during the war,
excepting from it only the
surviving regicides.
Eleven of those who had signed
Charles' death warrant were
executed and,
as you know,
the corpses of Cromwell and
Ireton were dug up and
desecrated.
Okay;
so far, so good.
But the so-called Cavalier
Parliament,
which was elected in 1661 to
replace the Convention
Parliament,
continued the process of the
Restoration in a manner which
turned out to be far more
generous to the crown and far
more vindictive to the crown's
former opponents.
All military authority was
vested in the King.
The crown was granted a regular
income of over a million pounds
a year from the customs and a
new tax, the Hearth Tax.
In 1662, a Licensing Act
re-imposed control of the press
which had been free for the
previous twenty years,
and above all two further steps
were taken.
First of all,
the Triennial Act was weakened.
It was altered to lay down that
the parliamentary sessions
should take place at least once
every three years,
but there were no mandatory new
elections as had originally been
intended.
In other words,
this gave the King the
opportunity to prolong an
existing parliament which was to
his taste by simply proroguing
it and then having it reassemble
at least once every three years;
and Charles took advantage of
that opportunity.
The Cavalier Parliament,
very favorable to the King,
elected in 1661,
was in fact continued without
new elections until 1668.
A second major change was that
the Cavalier Parliament showed
no willingness to grant liberty
of conscience to dissenters as
had been promised.
In 1662, the Church of England
was reestablished,
the prayer book was
reintroduced--very little
altered--
an Act of Uniformity was
imposed on the whole kingdom.
All clergy were required to
subscribe to the Act of
Uniformity or to be deprived of
their livings.
As a result,
hundreds who couldn't in
conscience subscribe,
were deprived.
And a number of additional acts
were introduced against
dissenters between 1661 and
1665.
They were banned from holding
office in any urban corporation.
In 1664, they were banned from
holding religious services.
Only services of the Church of
England were permitted.
A year later the Five Mile Act
banned dissenting clergymen from
living within five miles of any
corporate city;
places where traditionally they
had had a good deal of strength.
Now this was not what Charles
II wanted, it wasn't what the
Earl of Clarendon wanted,
but they accepted it.
As a result,
a large minority of the
population were forced in to the
position of being either active
or potential dissidents in
matters of religion.
Surveys that have been done
suggest that Protestant
dissenters made up about ten
percent of the entire
population,
though their strength varied a
great deal from area to area.
In some parts of the kingdom
they were very thin on the
ground,
the county of Shropshire,
for example,
on the Welsh border,
a survey done in 1672 reveals
very few of them.
On the other hand,
in the town of Colchester in
Essex on the east coast,
it's thought that as much as a
third of the population were
dissenters,
many of them Quakers.
And then, if we turn to London,
London appears to have had
about a fifth of its population
favoring dissent.
A minority, only a fifth,
but remember in a city the size
of London that meant a hundred
thousand people.
So, the Restoration had
restored too much.
It had gone back too far.
It restored not only the
consensual constitutional
position of 1641,
but also some of the tensions
and some of the stresses of the
1640s,
and it had weakened the
position of parliament in one
important respect,
by modifying the Triennial Act.
Well, obviously enough
religious dissenters had good
reason to be very quickly
disappointed and disillusioned
with the Restoration settlement,
but more broadly it took some
time before tensions began to
re-emerge fully.
Charles II was welcomed back as
the restorer of order.
He was young;
he was only thirty.
He was tall and handsome.
He was a man who was energetic
only in his sports and his
pleasures.
The fact that he has had many
mistresses is very well known.
He managed to father thirteen
illegitimate children,
all of whom were given the
surname Fitzroy,
"son of the king"--
Fitzrovia in the west end of
London is named after one of
them--
but he never managed to have a
legitimate heir.
He was happy to be king though.
He played the part well.
He was intelligent.
He was shrewd. He was affable.
He swanned around St.
James' Park with his spaniels
and his mistresses.
He attended meetings of the
Royal Society.
He showed his courage during
the great fire of London in 1666
when he joined in the
firefighting.
He knew he looked good in a wet
shirt.
>
But despite all of these
qualities Charles had no
particular political vision or
strategy, and perhaps that was
just as well.
He knew that beneath the public
celebrations of his restoration
the Restoration had been,
and in a very real sense
remained, essentially
conditional,
and he had no desire,
as he put it himself,
"to go on my travels
again."
He was happy to be back.
Nevertheless,
if he had no particular vision,
he did have his preferences and
from time to time they got him
into trouble.
Principal amongst them were
first of all his admiration for
the monarchy of his cousin,
King Louis XIV of France,
the so-called Sun King,
the absolute monarch of
Europe's emergent great power
and the very model of
monarchical magnificence,
displayed in his palace at
Versailles.
Secondly, there was Charles'
sympathy,
to put it no stronger,
for Roman Catholicism,
the religion of his mother,
as a religion which he regarded
as more suitable to monarchy.
And these preferences led him
into interconnected initiatives
in foreign policy and in matters
of religion which were
potentially alienating to some
of his subjects;
far more alienating than his
raffish court or his personal
debauchery.
In 1665 to '7,
England fought a brief and
unsuccessful naval war with the
Dutch, the Second Dutch War,
triggered off by commercial
rivalry.
It was a deeply humiliating
episode and especially so since
everyone remembered very well
Oliver Cromwell's military
strength and the triumph in the
First Dutch War in the 1650s.
Samuel Pepys,
Secretary of the Navy at this
time,
confided to his diary
repeatedly his dissatisfaction
with the manner in which the war
had been conducted;
his dissatisfaction with the
way in which the King and his
council would not attend to
business as had been done under
the previous regime.
As a result of the failures of
the Second Dutch War,
the Earl of Clarendon was
sacrificed as a scapegoat and he
was replaced with a ministry
which is known as the Cabal
after the initial letters of the
principal ministers:
Clifford,
Arlington, Buckingham,
Ashley Cooper,
and Lauderdale.
In 1670, under the Cabal
ministry Charles concluded the
Treaty of Dover with France.
In it he agreed to ally with
France in any future war against
the Dutch.
It was not popular with those
in the kingdom who saw France as
the truly rising threat of the
1660s,
potentially a new Spain aiming
at European dominance;
people who also saw the Dutch
as the principal opponents of
that French hegemony.
And the treaty would have been
even less popular if people had
known that it contained two
secret clauses.
First of all,
Charles had agreed secretly
that at an appropriate moment he
would suspend the penal laws
against Roman Catholics.
Secondly, he had agreed with
Louis that he would himself
convert to Catholicism at a
propitious moment.
In return for this he received,
again in secret,
a quarter of a million pounds a
year pension from France.
Well, in the aftermath of the
Treaty of Dover,
in 1672 Louis XIV declared war
on the Netherlands and invaded.
Charles issued a Declaration of
Indulgence in which he used his
power as supreme head of the
church to suspend the penal laws
against both Protestant
dissenters and Roman Catholics,
and indeed he allowed
dissenters to publicly worship
in licensed meeting houses.
Two days later England also
declared war on the Dutch,
the beginning of the Third
Dutch War.
This war proved again to be
very unpopular,
notably because it was highly
unsuccessful militarily and
there was a growing sympathy
amongst the political public
with the plucky Dutch and their
young leader,
William of Orange,
standing up against the French.
The Declaration of Indulgence
with its granting of a degree of
religious liberty to those other
than members of the Church of
England was even more unpopular
with the Anglican-dominated
Cavalier Parliament.
It met again in 1673 for a new
session and almost immediately
attacked the Declaration of
Indulgence,
declaring that "penal
statutes in matters
ecclesiastical cannot be
suspended but by an act of
parliament"
and that the suspending power
which the King had used was
innovatory.
"No such power,"
said the House of Commons,
"was ever claimed or
executed by his predecessors;.
Faced with this kind of
opposition from people who had
previously been his strongest
supporters, Charles backed down.
He showed his characteristic
unwillingness to push his own
preferences beyond the bounds of
political expediency.
The Declaration of Indulgence
was withdrawn and under the
threat of withholding supply for
the war effort he agreed to the
passage by parliament of the
Test Act.
The Test Act was an act laying
down that all officers of the
crown must swear the oath of
supremacy and allegiance and
take a declaration against the
Catholic doctrine of
transubstantiation and take
communion in the Church of
England;
so it was a test of Anglican
religious conformity.
Prominent amongst its early
victims were first of all Lord
Clifford,
one of Charles' chief ministers
who was a secret Catholic,
and secondly,
and even more importantly,
James, Duke of York,
Charles' younger brother who at
this point was,
of course, also the heir to the
throne since Charles and his
Portuguese wife,
Catherine of Braganza,
had had no children.
James had declared in 1673,
most un-propitiously,
his conversion to Catholicism.
Under the Test Act he was
excluded from high office.
Well, this debacle led to the
collapse of the Cabal ministry
and the appointment of a new
chief minister,
Thomas Osborne,
the Earl of Danby,
who was fiercely Anglican--
that satisfied the Cavalier
Parliament--
and who was also,
as it happened,
pro-Dutch.
But Charles was still secretly
getting a pension from the
French in return for keeping
parliament out of session as
much as possible.
In 1677, when he had to call it
again,
it met and tried to make the
voting of further taxes
conditional upon Charles joining
the Dutch-led alliance against
France.
And at this point the King
resisted successfully,
arguing that if he allowed
parliament to prescribe his
foreign policy "it is plain
that no prince or state in
Europe would any longer believe
that the sovereignty of England
rests in the crown."
So Charles took a stand on that
point,
but Danby nonetheless succeeded
in building at least one bridge
with the Dutch when,
in 1677, he was able to arrange
the marriage of Mary,
the daughter of James by an
earlier marriage,
Charles' niece and a Protestant
by upbringing.
Her marriage was arranged to
William of Orange,
an event which was to prove to
be of profound future
significance.
So, at this point Charles,
like his shrewd grandfather,
James I, had proved himself
flexible enough to avoid
provoking political crisis.
He knew when to give way as
well as when to stand.
But by the late 1670s anxieties
were growing about the threat of
'popery and arbitrary power' at
home as well as abroad.
It was made worse in 1674 when
the Duke of York,
now a declared--an openly
declared--
Catholic, married the Catholic
princess Mary of Modena,
which posed the risk that there
might be the birth of a future
heir to the throne who would be
brought up as a Roman Catholic.
There was also a growing sense
of distance between the court
and the country and a growing
suspicion of the King's
intentions.
It was in 1677 that Andrew
Marvell,
best known today as a poet but
at that time member of
parliament for the town of Hull
in Yorkshire,
published, without putting his
name on it,
"An Account of the Growth
of Popery and Arbitrary
Power" in which he argued
in his pamphlet that he could
discern a plot to introduce what
we--
what he--described as
"absolute tyranny,"
"French slavery,"
and "Popish
Idolatry."
These were the fears that were
circulating amongst Charles'
opponents in parliament.
Clearly, we've been here before.
The highly combustible elements
of seventeenth-century English
political paranoia were being
mixed again,
and the spark which was needed
to cause a near explosion was
provided in the autumn of 1678
when one Titus Oates laid
allegations of a Jesuit plot to
murder King Charles in order to
hasten the succession of his
brother,
James, to the throne.
This was the beginning of the
so-called Popish Plot affair.
That Titus Oates' wild
allegations were seriously
listened to by parliament and by
the political public in general
can be explained only by the
pre-existing atmosphere of
suspicion which had been
building up in the 1670s.
But the allegations soon
acquired greater credibility.
Sir Edmund Berry Godfrey,
the London magistrate who had
taken Oates' allegations,
was found murdered.
Then a search of the house of
Prince James' former secretary,
Edward Coleman,
revealed real correspondence
between the Duke of York's
secretary and Jesuits.
Then there was the revelation
in December 1678 in parliament,
by an aggrieved former
ambassador, of the secret
clauses of the Treaty of Dover
of 1670,
which caused uproar.
Parliament attempted to impeach
the Earl of Danby for his share
of responsibility for royal
policy and Charles was forced at
last to dissolve the Cavalier
Parliament in January 1679.
The Popish Plot precipitated
what Jonathan Scott has
described as the second great
"crisis of popery and
arbitrary power";
the Exclusion Crisis as it's
called,
running from 1679 to 1681:
Exclusion Crisis because it
involved attempts by parliament
to exclude James,
Duke of York,
heir to the throne,
from the succession.
The first Exclusion Parliament
met between March and May 1679.
Elections to this new
parliament, the first elections
held since 1661,
took place in an atmosphere of
tremendous political excitement.
When it met the Earl of Danby
was sent to the Tower of London
where he remained for the next
five years.
Parliament then proposed a bill
to exclude James,
Duke of York,
from the succession and
persisted in demanding this
despite King Charles' offer that
he would have limits put upon
the powers of appointment of any
future Catholic king.
He was willing to give way to
some degree.
Beyond that,
however, Charles was ready to
resist.
Defending the legitimate
succession to the throne was one
issue that he would fight for.
Parliament was dissolved and
James was sent off to Scotland
to keep him out of harm's way.
This crisis now unleashed
political agitation and popular
involvement in politics of a
kind which really hadn't been
seen since the 1640s.
There was tremendous debate
over the exclusion issue in the
coffeehouses and taverns of
London and the other major
cities;
this debate fueled by an
outbreak of pamphleteering which
was possible because the
Licensing Act controlling the
press had actually expired in
1679 and parliament had been
dissolved before it had time to
renew it.
Temporarily,
the press was free again.
Mass demonstrations took place
in London calling for a new
parliament.
These street demonstrations
were orchestrated by a former
member of Charles' government,
the Earl of Shaftesbury,
and his friends in the
so-called Green Ribbon Club,
but they also demonstrated
genuine popular concern.
There was a real basis of
popular concern which
Shaftesbury and his friends
successfully mobilized.
But the agitation wasn't all
one way.
As the crisis deepened,
the emergence of two new terms
in politics took place,
Whigs and Tories,
terms which were adopted to
describe different political
positions both inside and
outside parliament over the
issue of exclusion.
The so-called Whigs specialized
in mounting processions through
London at which--which tended to
culminate in the burning of
effigies of the pope.
They placed great emphasis upon
the threat of popery.
They placed a great deal of
emphasis also on the threat of
arbitrary power.
They talked a lot about the
need to defend England's
religion,
liberties and property,
and called for a new parliament
which alone could save the day,
in their view.
The Tories on the other hand
placed their confidence in the
King.
They branded the Whigs as being
predominantly dissenters in
sympathy religiously,
as closet Presbyterians,
as fomenters of insurrection
against the King,
as secret Republicans,
as a threat to the Church of
England and to England's true
liberties.
They repeatedly played upon the
threat of a new 1641,
a new slide into civil war.
Behind these insulting labels
Whig and Tory,
then, lay emerging political
alignments rooted in differences
of political principle,
and these divisions,
as I've said,
were to be found not only
amongst members of parliament
but also permeated deeply down
through society beyond the
political elite to the middle
sort of people,
those who supported the
demonstrations of one side or
another.
Okay.
Well, this fevered atmosphere
in the late 1670s and early
1680s provided the background to
the parliamentary politics of
those years.
In October 1680,
another new parliament met.
This one's usually known as the
Second Exclusion Parliament.
Again the House of Commons
declared that it would grant
supply of money to the crown
only in return for a new
exclusion bill.
Charles promptly dissolved it
in January 1681 and called for
yet another parliament this time
to meet not in London but in the
friendly city of Oxford,
two months later.
The King was clearly playing
for time.
In March 1681,
the Oxford Parliament met,
again in an atmosphere of
tremendous public agitation.
It was in the course of the
Oxford parliament that the
incident took place in which the
King's mistress,
Nell Gwyn, the actress,
proceeding to Oxford in her
coach in order to join the King,
found herself surrounded by an
angry mob who thought she was
the Duchess of Portsmouth,
another of Charles' mistresses
who happened to be a Catholic.
Nell Gwyn was able to get the
crowd to leave her alone by
opening the door,
showing herself and crying,
"Be still,
good people.
I am the Protestant whore."
>
Meanwhile, in Oxford,
the House of Commons still
demanded the exclusion of James,
Duke of York,
from the succession.
Charles roundly declared that
he would not have it and he
dissolved them again.
So what next?
Charles couldn't face another
parliament, but he decided to
call the Whigs' bluff and to
brazen it out in the absence of
a sitting parliament.
He trusted in the possibility
that he might be able to rally
support in the political nation
at large,
largely by appealing to Tory
sympathizers and partly by
playing on the widespread fears
that if this agitation continued
it might lead to another
breakdown;
another '41.
In April of 1681,
he issued a studiously moderate
declaration of his position and
ordered that it should be read
out from the pulpit of every
parish church in England;
and so it was.
In his declaration the King
explained the basis of his
principled conduct in defending
the legitimate succession to the
throne.
He revived memories of the
breakdown in to civil war and
how that war had led to the
abolition of the Church of
England,
to military rulership and the
subjugation of English liberties
and threats to property.
And it worked.
No parliament was sitting to
focus opposition to the King.
Agitation was gradually dying
down and Charles pressed his
advantage hard.
Titus Oates was arrested and
tried for perjury,
found guilty,
his allegations declared false,
and he was punished in the
pillory.
The Earl of Shaftesbury,
leader of the Whigs,
was indicted for treason.
He fled abroad where he shortly
died.
Charles then began a systematic
program of calling in and
remodeling the charters of
England's cities as a means of
purging the corporations which
supported Whigs in national
politics and thereby rendering
the cities which elected members
of parliament more politically
controllable.
Between 1681 and 1685,
fifty-one cities had their
charters remodeled in this way
to make them more politically
manipulable;
forty-seven more were still in
the pipeline in 1685.
Charles also permitted the
intensified prosecution of
dissenters in order to satisfy
Anglican prejudices and to cow
the dissenters themselves.
The Quakers suffered especially
severely during the persecutions
of the early 1680s.
In 1683, with the discovery of
an alleged plot against the
king,
the Rye House Plot,
Whig radicals were arrested and
two leading Whig leaders,
Lord Russell and Algernon
Sidney, were brought to trial,
found guilty and executed.
Finally, in 1684 Charles
further consolidated his
position by defying the
Triennial Act.
Under the Triennial Act he
should have called a new
parliament that year.
He didn't.
So, Charles II had faced the
crisis of his reign at last,
proven himself when stirred to
be politically pretty astute,
and he had won.
In February 1685,
when the King was suddenly
incapacitated by a stroke and
then died after a short illness,
he had never been stronger.
And it was on his death bed
that at last he found the
propitious moment he had been
waiting for and converted to
Catholicism.
Well, Charles had won by
gambling that in the absence of
a sitting parliament which could
focus opposition,
no one could face the prospect
of armed rebellion against him;
no one could face a renewal of
civil war.
He had consolidated his
position by appealing to the
fears and the prejudices of the
Tory-Anglican majority amongst
the political nation at large,
and he had demonstrated that a
Protestant authoritarianism was
not necessarily unacceptable to
those people.
It's interesting indeed to
speculate as to whether if James
II,
Charles' successor,
had continued to build up an
enhanced royal power on that
basis,
whether England might have
become a Protestant absolutist
state like Sweden or Denmark.
Not impossible,
but we'll never know,
because if Charles II had had a
lot in common with his
grandfather,
James I, James II proved to be
rather closer in temperament to
his father,
Charles I.
In a sense he was a better man
morally than his brother
Charles,
but he also suffered far too
much from energy,
coupled with a catastrophic
lack of political judgment.
James couldn't leave well alone.
Initially, his position was
very strong.
His first parliament was Tory
dominated and it was willing to
trust him despite his Roman
Catholicism.
Parliament was generous to him
indeed in its financial grants.
And then in the summer of 1685
when Charles II's illegitimate
son,
the Duke of Monmouth,
landed in the west of England,
raised a small army and claimed
to be the legitimate heir to the
throne,
parliament quickly granted
James the resources for more
troops to head west and crush
the rebellion swiftly.
And yet, despite this strength
in the first year of his reign,
in less than three years James
managed to undermine his own
position with a quite staggering
comprehensiveness.
The problem was,
of course, James' religion.
It need not have been a
problem, but he made it one.
He was a deeply sincere
Catholic with all of the zeal of
a convert.
He probably didn't intend to
impose his religion coercively
upon the nation,
but he was certainly determined
to remove the disabilities of
his co-religionists and to
promote their interests,
and he doubtless hoped that
with more widespread conversions
to Catholicism eventually the
nation would move back gradually
in a Catholic direction.
These were not ignoble aims
from James' point of view,
but of course in the conditions
of late seventeenth-century
England they constituted gross
political folly,
especially in the 1680s at a
time when King Louis XIV of
France had recently revoked the
toleration previously granted
under Richelieu to French
Protestants and England was
receiving thousands of
Protestant refugees from Louis'
brutal persecutions in France.
What James needed if he was to
proceed with his intentions was
to get the Test Acts repealed.
Parliament clearly was not
willing to grant that,
so James turned instead to his
use of his prerogative powers
and in particular to his
'dispensing power'.
Theoretically,
the king was permitted to
dispense particular individuals
from the penalties of the law in
special cases where rigid
enforcement of the letter of the
law might result in an
injustice.
This prerogative power,
however, did not extend to
authorizing acts which were
contrary to the law pure and
simple.
It was meant for occasional use
in special cases.
James' use of the dispensing
power showed a lack of respect
for that distinction in the law
and was deeply provocative.
Indeed, the manner in which it
was used was so provocative as
to be almost farcical in
retrospect.
One almost imagines that James
and his cabinet were meeting
every morning and asking
themselves,
"what can we do today
which will really upset
people?"
>
Let's have some Catholics in
the privy council;
four of them. Okay. Great.
How about making your Jesuit
confessor a member of the
cabinet?
Sweet.
>
Let's make 250 Catholics
justices of the peace in the
counties and displace their
Protestant predecessors.
Wonderful idea.
Let's appoint Catholic officers
in the militia and the army.
Let's appoint a Catholic Lord
Deputy of Ireland and allow him
to re-catholicize the army
there.
Let's make an Oxford College a
Catholic seminary.
Wonderful ideas;
and he did it all.
Now James was not so stupid as
not to realize that this policy
would be deeply alienating to
Anglican support,
but he thought that he could
counterbalance that by wooing
support amongst Protestant
dissenters.
In April 1687,
he himself issued a Declaration
of Indulgence,
like his brother,
suspending the penal laws
against both dissenters and
Roman Catholics.
In sum then,
the king's dispensing power was
being exercised with a freedom
that was clearly turning it into
an illegal suspension of the
law,
the very thing which parliament
had declared against in 1673.
And James appeared to be
forcing his base of support,
his natural allies amongst
Tories and staunch Anglicans,
he was forcing them to choose
between their loyalty to their
church and their loyalty to the
King.
To make matters worse,
in 1687 James embarked upon
what appeared to be a blatant
attempt to pack a future
parliament for the purpose of
securing the repeal of the Test
Acts.
All justices of peace in the
counties and members of urban
corporations for parliamentary
constituencies were asked by the
King to answer three questions
relating to whether or not they
would support repeal of the Test
Acts in a new parliament,
whether or not they would vote
for those who would support such
a repeal if they were elected to
parliament,
and whether they would support
the new Declaration of
Indulgence.
James could hardly have
signaled his intentions more
clearly,
and by doing so he occasioned
widespread alarm,
not just among Anglicans but
also amongst the majority of the
dissenters whom he had been
trying to woo.
They were not disposed to trust
the King's good intentions.
At this point anxieties was
perhaps only contained by
expectations that this situation
might not last too long.
King James was now fifty-five
years old, quite a good age for
the time.
He still had no son.
His eldest daughter,
Mary, his heir,
was a Protestant and was
married to William of Orange in
the Netherlands.
If the King were to die soon,
then they would surely succeed
and it might well be the case
that toleration would be
achieved for Protestant
dissenters without empowering
Roman Catholics in the way James
was doing.
That may have been many
people's hope,
but in the winter of 1687 and
the spring of 1688 two
precipitants transformed the
situation.
First of all,
in November 1687,
it became known that Queen Mary
was pregnant and that the
pregnancy was going well.
James might then have a
Catholic heir if a son was born.
Secondly, in April 1688 James
ordered his Declaration of
Indulgence to be read out in all
Anglican churches.
Seven bishops of the Church of
England, including the
Archbishop of Canterbury
himself, petitioned against this
action.
In reply they were indicted and
tried for sedition.
The case of the Seven Bishops
turned on the legality of the
use of the dispensing power by
the King and when it was heard
they were acquitted,
to widespread public rejoicing.
And then, in June 1688 Queen
Mary was delivered of a child,
a prince, the young Prince
James.
Rumors immediately began to
circulate that in fact the child
was not the King's child but had
been smuggled in to the Queen's
bedchamber secretly in a warming
pan in order to give the
appearance of the birth of an
heir to the throne.
People were now so desperate
they were willing to believe
stories of this kind,
or pretend they did.
All of this persuaded seven
leading politicians,
five of them Whigs,
two of them Tories,
including the Earl of Danby,
Charles' former chief minister,
that it was time to do
something.
This was the third "crisis
of popery and arbitrary
power," and in June 1688
these seven leaders,
who later became known as the
'Immortal Seven',
sent a letter to William of
Orange expressing their fear for
their liberties,
their religion,
and their property and inviting
him to intervene to secure a
free Parliament and to
investigate the suspicious
circumstances of Prince James'
birth.
William had in fact already
been anticipating the likelihood
of renewed war with France in
1688 and he had made contingency
plans for the possible invasion
of England if,
as he expected,
James II supported Louis XIV of
France against him.
Louis was indeed ready to
support James in such an
eventuality,
but the autumn of 1688 came and
no one expected an invasion
later than that because of the
prevalence of adverse winds in
the English Channel.
By September 1688 then,
Louis of France considered
himself free of that threat and
obligation and he moved his
troops south in order to invade
the Palatinate in south Germany;
the first steps in a renewed
war.
This freed William of Orange
from fear of an immediate French
attack upon the Netherlands.
In October 1688,
he issued a declaration that he
was coming over in order
"to preserve and maintain
the established laws,
liberties and customs"
of England and to investigate
the birth of the prince.
On the 1^(st) of November,
he sailed and was carried down
the Channel by what was later
known as the "Protestant
wind," a wind blowing
unusually in the right direction
for his purposes.
He was carried down the channel
to land at Torbay in the west of
England on the 5^(th) of
November 1688,
a very propitious day.
Faced with this invasion,
King James initially joined his
army at Salisbury in the West
Country but inexplicably lost
his nerve and withdrew to
London.
James was no coward,
he'd fought very bravely in his
youth, but for some reason he
lost his nerve and withdrew.
His army's leaders went over to
William and joined him.
Risings also began to take
place in some provincial cities.
The Earl of Danby for example
seized York with parties of the
Yorkshire gentry.
At this point King James sent
his family abroad for safety and
on the 11^(th) of December
himself attempted to flee,
throwing the great seal of
England into the river Thames
before doing so in an effort to
paralyze the government which
needed the great seal for
various acts.
James was captured by a fishing
boat on his way out of England
and returned to London where he
was held in custody until the
20^(th) of December when he
again escaped,
probably by collusion on the
part of William's supporters,
who allowed him to escape.
Indeed his escape was vital.
What would they have done if
James had stayed?
They'd have been back in the
position of 1648 of negotiations
with Charles I.
But with James gone the
political process could proceed
in his absence.
He was allowed to escape to
France,
and on the 24^(th) of December
1688 an assembly of the nobility
asked William and Mary to take
up the reins of government.
The way was prepared for a
refashioning of government which
was to proceed over the next two
decades and which was to
transform the British
constitution.
But I'll return to that after
the break.
Next time we need to look at
some other developments which
were taking place in the late
seventeenth century,
the extraordinary economic
growth of that period.